الاستعداد لمعركه هذا ما يقوم به الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دون الترامب قبل جلسه
محاكمته المقرره الثلاثاء وفق محاميه من
المتوقع ان يسافر ترامب الى مدينه نيويورك
برفقه اعضاء من الخدمه السريه الامريكيه
من منزله في مارلاجو الاثنين ثم يخطط
للعوده الى فلوريدا بعد جلسه محاكمته حيث
سيخاطب انصاره بحسب محاميه ستحارب اي
اتهامات ضد الرئيس السابق بقوه وسيمثل
امام محكمه نيويورك لابلاغه بتهمه جنائيه
موجهه اليه في قضيه دفع اموال لممثله
اباحيه بغيه شراء صمتها من المتوقع ان
يسلم نفسه للسلطات يوم الثلاثاء ومن
المقرر عقد جلسه استماع ظهرا في منهات ولن
تقيد يدات ترامب وبحسب محاميه التفاصيل
الاخرى للاستدعاء لا تزال غامضه بحكمه انه
امر غير مسبوق
لا تزال تفاصيل التهم بما في ذلك مهيتها
وعددها طي الكتمان وفق محاميه وسط نفيا
بارتكابها من قبل ترامب تقارير اعلاميه
افادت بان ترامب سيواجهه اكثر من 30 تهمه
تتعلق بالاحتيال التجاري لدفع 130 الف
دولار
في محاوله لشراء صمتها بشان علاقه جنسيه
مزعومه وسائل اعلام امريكيه ذكرت بان
ترامب متهم بتزوير سجلات تجاريه من الدرجه
الاولى وهي جنايه بموجب القانون الامريكي
ومن المقرر تنظيم تجمع حاشد لترامب مع
النائبه الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب مارجوري
ظهر الثلاثاء بنيويورك داعيه ان صار ترامب
للانضمام الى احتجاج سلمي ضد لائحه
الاتهام رش خياط العربيه